c-double-a basketball tournament is
underway I gotta tell you I love college
basketball so I'm very excited Andy
aren't you excited
now really Conan I'm not into sports all
right but you must know a little bit
about sports Andy not at all Conan come
on Andy not even the most basic details
nope
then you know what it's time for huh I
sure do
all right it's time for Andy Richter
Sports blasts
[Applause]
[Music]
okay class let's blast some sports
sports the college basketball games are
in full swing and that's what we in the
sports business call
March craziness marks craziness so let's
head over to the wall of basketball full
of basketballs Mart sprays and is kicked
off this weekend when the original 38
seedlings were whittled down to the sour
11 salary liveth let's take a look at
the bracket sports now nice bracket huh
as you can see there's a lot going on
there so I'm not even gonna try to
figure it out now here's our sport West
correspondent Conan O'Brien with a bunch
of batting averages yeah thanks a lot
Andy 350 292 to 78 378 253 332 and 301
you gotta love correct nice job Conan
now let's wrap it up with the sports
click with the week sports clip of the
week Wow Conan that was great Thank You
sports you okay Annie where the courts
yeah there you go
you